there's one for nineteen for so good
it's relaxing Davenant great because i
have two years in arrears it felt it
felt good cuz i was getting money back
it's gonna feel horrible because i owe
money i just handed them in just now it
feels good good I just as soon as I get
my w2 it's the first thing I do is do my
taxes I did it on my own for the first
time this year and I'm a little bit
nervous about actually surely that's
good feels good well it's good to have
that off my chest well it to be done
with them as five I don't feel as good
about where they are going terrible I'm
four I'm bitter and I'm frustrated I
don't like probably half of the Fayette
snow I feel really strongly about the
other half I mean I think there's a lot
of necessary services and I feel good
about funding those awfully awfully bad
it's amazing to me that we have children
who aren't covered with proper health
care and you know if my money was going
towards helping the right people I'd
feel differently but right now I feel
pretty crappy I'm actually quite upset
about it I think that we can spend her
money and other things that would
mutually benefit everyone I feel very
badly about it and if my taxes weren't
withdrawn from my paycheck I would not
pay my taxes out of protest I
it's a hard job to do and I think that
they're doing the best that they can
with the resources that they have really
I don't really feel like I'd know really
exactly what exactly everything goes to
I'm not sure if I can hi so I'm really
not sure but I don't feel very positive
about it you know obviously you can't
always be a hundred percent happy and
there's going to be people that are more
happy than others so you take it ticket
when you can get it and we can't get it
the way you want it you just deal has
anyone told you that they think the
government is spending our money well
and so much of our military spending is
going towards Cold War weapon systems
that were planned you know a decade ago
I would say I feel bitter and frustrated
and angry about the way the government
spends my money
well I'm gonna screw our economy and
save it cuz I don't think it's a good
idea right now the way the economy is
going I put it in the bank I don't
intend on spending it and I don't think
it's a good idea that they send it out
in the first place video games I'm gonna
fly to San Diego and I'm gonna go to
comic-con and buy some comic books
probably paying some of my crushing
debts probably savings just put it in my
savings what I did with my refund that I
got already just put in my savings
actually I was independent last year so
I don't get that refund check so I don't
really want to talk about it um probably
paying more bills you know i'm going to
use it probably just pay some bills well
i'll probably save a little bit and then
i'll probably use a little bit for to
pay for the tax bite i just paid for in
sending in my taxes so that's about it
yeah well I'll tell you what I'm going
to have to do I'm going to have to spend
more money this year on food which is
one of my major expenses and other major
expense for me is maintaining my car I
just had a 360 dollar a bill on you know
car repairs
and you
hello
hey
you